оркестр і червона дуриш так за
звучним протоколом у берліні за
зустрічаючись прем'єр-міністра України
Володимира Гройсмана
у його париж та робочої поїздки до Європи
звичайним їй катуючи її як і ми закрилися
нового прем'єра і зараз зустрічі з
німецьким експертом це політикам і
корупція повели нести реформи вина на
сході України прем'єр заповнюючи аудиторію
багата рахунок же зроду але не хочеться хочеться
актив дорівнює повинною абстрактну а
конкретно сказати все саме і я
збираюся змінити їм план
українського міста на ступні 2 3 роки
зокрема volosi економіки то реформ на
тому місці прем'єру вигляд і адже наступаючи
на мозолі європейців і на році та про
чуйної річки блукати коридорам інституті
спш проводження деки crane по слабо то
санкції проти Росії
тигони можна руб цієї кожен гройсман
oijanen зрощений вигляд ступивши інший від
прав там і євросоюзу виду України
миколу чую
про те ще вид України і в тому
червона відразу за намагаюся своїх спі можливо
ким невже поважає ще той мій вигляд
україна можна ловити росії як ви
карстові свою ризикову меч до того
щоб прямо його ти нас роботи ви
Беркетт позовом ієни в тому обожнювання видно
ви це економічні політично
уряд з росією навчаю мій великий
значення для не матч він і ви знаєте
німецькі експерти сама тому на їхню думку
україна мій опікун а ти чого на борту
того щуп захід за нею боровся а для тіла
новий прем'єр музика сам перед клас
ти край трубки це олігархи і до цього
такою проблемою в Україні я розучилася
соціально нас провідні весь я просто на
йому поверну багатів олігархи та людей кіно
пряму видних заклали з берега ти
petrenko Європи новому прем'єри буду
взагалі не жку піднімав здається німецькі
експерти повіту вдалося а владно
щурів brexit їй нести з бігти і ще
там і все закласти на скільки швидкою
успішно новий український та ряд за
проводити реформи та біракан
брюссель у своїй бездарності